if the Quran is not mentioned in the
previous scriptures then that means that
the Quran will be false right for making
a false claim
yeah
[Music]
God what's up
fly yo what it do what it
do um the verses you quote was it 19 192
to 196 yes chap 26: 192 to
196 perfect uh let me just read
it this is certainly a revelation from
your Lord of all worlds which the
trustworth which the trustworthy Spirit
Gabriel brought down into your heart or
Prophet so that you may be one of the
Warners in a clear Arabic tongue and it
has indeed been foretold in the
scripture of in the scriptures of days
before is that what you're talking about
yes because so the thing that's been for
told here is
the is in verse 190 the revelation of
your lord and the context of this
chapter talking
about uh already having one God that's
the Revelation and I don't see how you
that's not in the Bible I feel that you
guys only believe in one
God it says that the Quran itself is
mentioned in the
scriptures what does it say that
196 I
196 yeah so it says this it has indeed
been foretold in the scriptures of those
before
yep yeah and if you read from the
context it's talking about the
Revelation what what Revelation is it
talking about specifically pardon what
Revelation is it talking about
specifically that is really one quot no
that's not what it says brother did you
read the whole chapter I don't have
to what what you were just talking to
the other guy about the
context yeah that's why so the the verse
that I'm talking about specifically is
196 and I read one I started at 192 for
context yeah that's not good enough you
need to start like 150 it's talking
about how the different prophets came
and said fear Allah fear Allah the one
good all right so let's do this let's do
this
together 192
says and truly this is a revelation from
the Lord of mankind what is the this
that it's talking
about the
Revelation it says this is a revelation
so what is the this that is a
revelation that is one
good okay let's keep
going man 193 which the trustworthy Rook
has brought
down what is the
Revelation that the trustworthy Rook
brought
down there's only one God I don't see
what the problem is what was the what's
the Revelation that he brought
down that there's only one
God yeah guys
can't brother do you know what Quran
means let's keep going 194 upon your
heart oh Muhammad that you may be of the
Warners what did the trustworthy Spirit
what is the Revelation that the
trustworthy Spirit brought down upon
Muhammad
you my question first of all it's been
the same question that you haven't been
answering what is that Revelation that
the trustworthy Spirit has brought down
upon Muhammad's heart what is it that
there's only one God this chapter is
literally about those what is it that
there's only one God answered that five
times so can you answer my question now
195 in the plain Arabic
language what is this revelation that
came down from the trustworthy spirit
that he put upon Muhammad's
heart that is in clear Arabic
language that there's only one
go
bro take care
F so now guys we're at this point where
now Muslims are afraid to say that it's
the Quran
now now we're at the point where Muslims
can't even say it's the
Quran that's where we're at that's how
tough this question
is that that's how tough this question
is this question is so tough that
Muslims are afraid of telling us what
the Quran
is this Revelation that was given to
Muhammad from the trustworthy spirit in
plain Arabic
language that's mentioned in the
previous scriptures what is that oh that
there's only one
God that there's only one
God what am I supposed to do with that
man
what are the other Muslims listening to
you supposed to do with
that I never thought I'd see the day
where these guys are afraid to say what
the Quran is guys I never thought I'd
see the day it's just one
question it's a simple question ladies
and
gentlemen where in the
Bible does it mention Al
Quran hello yeah hello how how do I say
your name so I don't butcher it zero
zero zero yes got it got it zero okay
all right welcome to the
panel yeah thank you man thank you how
are you a man I'm blessed the Lord Jesus
Christ has been so good to me bro yeah
nice nice that's good that's good to
hear thank you okay I want to begin with
uh with the
first
578 Christ the son of Mary was no more
than a messenger many were the
messengers that passed away before him
his mother was a saintly woman they both
ate Earthly food see how clearly make
for them our messages yet see how they
are deluded away from the
truth 578 thank thanks for that um so do
you uh do you see the title of the
room yeah Quran mentioned in the bible
mhm Quran mentioned in the bible yes yes
so so I'm asking where does the Bible
mention the
Quran where does the yeah because the
Quran the Quran says that it's mentioned
in the previous scripture so I want to
know
where
okay I understand yeah so I want I want
to make sure that you I'm clear on what
I'm asking so I'm not asking where is
Muhammad mentioned in the scriptures I'm
asking where's the Quran mentioned in
the scriptures because that's what
chapter 26 vers 196 says it says the
Quran is mentioned in the previous
scriptures all right all right all right
I
understand I don't know man Fair that's
a that's a fair question a that not
that's a fair response that's a fair
response so let me ask you this
okay if the Quran is not mentioned in
the previous scriptures that that means
that the Quran will be false right for
making a false
claim
right
yeah so is it fair of
me as a Christian who reads the previous
scriptures and I also read the Quran and
I saw where the Quran says that the
Quran itself is mentioned in my
scriptures
and I read the scriptures and I never
see the mention of the
Quran oh he's
gone
guys hold on let me check the guest to
make
sure he's
gone
ohime
bro what is up
I mean not even the prove Jesus was a
Muslim question challenge makes them run
away like this these guys are running
away with this
question hold on guys don't don't bring
nobody up if I don't say guys let me
bring the people up I'll bring the
people up okay you know um I dropped Fly
for a reason because fly was actually
afraid to say what the Quran is he was
afraid admit that this is that the Quran
is the Arabic Revelation supposedly that
was given to Muhammad from the
trustworthy Spirit he's the he's the bot
that kept
saying to believe in one God to believe
in one God it's the same to believe in
one God believe in one God he's the same
bot that was doing that so he for he
forfeited this guy that we just
had started off it seemed to be
honest ran away
got out of here quick
y'all got out of here so quick this is
tough I haven't I I haven't seen one
like this before I haven't seen a qu one
question makes so many Muslims run
away oh my God
logic
n